[Music]
we don't sleep much thirty hours and
building straight I start my week on a
Wednesday we'll go Wednesday I start the
week we go to the table read with we
read about 40 some-odd scripts from that
40 scripts they'll pick about 14 to 15
that we're going to produce we'll start
either Wednesday night at oval if it's
not that crazy we'll start on Thursday
morning
[Music]
one of the things that I've got to
really think about when I'm turning
somebody into a political character is
not losing the cast member if cait's
gotta be robert muller or if she's if
she's got to be Jeff Sessions I've got
to kind of trying to keep a little bit
of sessions in there but also still be
able to see that it's Kate McKinnon it's
finding a subtle caricature of the of
the political person bald cap so the
whole one of the hardest things to get
on we just did when Kevin Hart hosted a
couple a couple of weeks ago he had to
be fully bald and I think I had a
commercial break to make him fully bald
and normally a bald cap takes my fastest
is six six minutes and that's with four
guys gluing and paid and painting this
was me and Amy tagged a Monty and I
think we had a commercial break to put
it on which like two minutes to turn a
ball the trick is having a great team
working
[Music]
you